I once saw a high school teacher lead a
simple powerful exercise to teach his
class about privilege and social
mobility
he started by giving each student a
scrap piece of paper and asked them to
crumple it up then he moved the
recycling bin to the front of the room
he said the game is simple you all
represent the country's population and
everyone in the country has a chance to
become wealthy and move into the upper
class to move into the upper class all
you must do is throw your water-type
paper into the bin while sitting in your
seat the students in the back of the
room immediately piped up saying this is
unfair they could see the rows of
students in front of them had a much
better chance everyone took their shots
and as expected most of the students in
the front made it but not all and only a
few students in the back of the room
ated he concluded by saying the closer
you were to the recycling bin the better
your odds this is what privilege looks
like did you notice how the only ones
who complained about fairness were in
the back of the room by contrast people
in the front of the room were less
likely to be aware of the privilege they
were born into all they can see is 10
feet between them and their goal your
job as students who are receiving an
education is to be aware of your
privilege and use this particular
privilege called education to do your
best to achieve great things all the
while advocating for those in the rows
behind you